what we're going to do in this video is
learn how to use a graphing calculator
in particular a ti-84 if you're using
any other ti texas instrument calculator
it'll be very similar in order to answer
some questions dealing with geometric
random variables so here we have a
scenario i keep picking cards from a
standard deck until i get a king so this
is a classic geometric random variable
here and it's important that in this
parenthesis it says i replace the cards
if they are not a king and this is
important as we talk about in other
videos because the probability of
success each time can't change and so
we could define some random variable x
this is a geometric random variable as
being equal to the number
of
picks
until
until we get a king
until we get a king when we replace the
cards if they are not a king and for
this geometric random variable what's
the probability of success on each trial
and remember one of the conditions for a
geometric random variable is that
probability of success does not change
on each trial well the probability of
success is going to be equal to there's
four kings in a standard deck of 52 and
this is the same thing as 1 over 13.
so this first question is what is the
probability that i need to pick five
cards
well this would be the probability that
our geometric random variable x is equal
to five and you could actually figure
this out by hand but the whole point
here is to think about how to use a
calculator and there is a function
called geomet
f which stands for geometric
probability distribution function where
what you have to pass it is the
probability of success on any given
trial 1 out of 13 and then the
particular pro the particular value of
that random variable that you want to
figure out the probability for so 5
right over there now just to be clear if
you're doing this as on an ap exam and
this is one of the reasons why a
calculator is useful you actually can
use this on an ap exam ap statistics
exam
it's important to tell the graders if
you're doing on the free response
that this right over here is your p and
that this right over here is your five
just so it's very clear that where you
actually got this information from or
why you're actually typing it in but
let's just see how it works what this
probability is actually going to amount
to
all right so i have my calculator now
and i just need to type in geomet pdf
and then those parameters and so the
place where i find that function i press
second
distribution right over here this little
blue above the vars button
and then i can click up i could scroll
down or i could just go to the bottom of
the list and you can see the second from
the bottom is geomet pdf click enter
there my p value my probability of
success on each trial is 1 out of 13 and
i want to figure out the probability
that i have to pick
five cards
and so then click enter
click enter again and there you have it
it's about 0.056
so this is approximately
approximately 0.056
now let's answer another question so
here they say what is the probability
that i need to pick less than 10 cards
so this is the probability that x is
less than 10
or i could say this is equal to the
probability that x is less than or equal
to 9
and i could say well this is the
probability that x is equal to 1 plus
the probability that x is equal to 2
all the way to the probability that x is
equal to 9 but that would take a while
even if i used this function right over
here but lucky for us there's a
cumulative distribution function take
some space from the next question this
is going to be equal to geo
met cdf cumulative distribution function
and once again i passed the probability
of success on any trial and then up to
and including
nine and so let's get the calculator out
again
so we go to second distribution i click
up and there we have geomet cumulative
distribution function press enter
1 out of 13 chance of success on any
trial up to and including nine
and then
enter and there you have it it's
approximately
51.3 percent or 0.513
so this is approximately 0.5
now let's do one more what is the
probability that i need to pick more
than 12 cards and like i'll pause the
video and see if you can figure this one
out what function would i use on my
calculator or how would i set it up
well the probability this is the
probability that x is going to be
greater than 12 which is
equal to 1 minus the probability that x
is less than or equal to 12. and now
this we can just use the cumulative
distribution function again so this is 1
minus
geo
met
cdf cumulative distribution function
c
df of
1 over 13 and up to and including 12.
and so what is this going to be equal to
so second
distribution
i click up i get to the function
click enter and so i already have that
first the probability of success on
every trial is 1 over 13 and then
cumulative up to 12
and so i click
enter
and then well i could click enter there
but i really want to get 1 minus this
value and so i can do 1
minus
2nd
answer
which would be just 1 minus that value
which will be equal to
there you have it it's about 38.3
percent or 0.383 so this is
approximately equal to 0.383
and we're done